-Donald Trump
has appealed a ruling
in the case over his
stolen top-secret documents
directly to the Supreme Court --
and specifically
Justice Clarence Thomas,
whose wife, Ginni Thomas,
has been implicated
in Trump's attempted coup
and whom Trump praised publicly
at a recent rally --
posing a major test
for the strength
of our constitutional system.
Also in an equally
important story,
Trump reportedly complained
about how awful
Rudy Giuliani's [bleep] smelled.
Those two stories
are both important.
[ Laughter ]
They are the same level
of importance.
We're going to talk
about them the same amount
because they matter the same.
[ Laughter ]
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Every so often a story comes
along that makes us throw out
everything we are planning
on doing that night on the show,
a blockbuster story
of monumental consequence
to the nation.
It happened many times
during the Trump presidency --
the Mueller investigation, two
impeachments, an attempted coup.
And look, I don't want to say
that our audience expects
or needs us
to provide this service,
but we feel a moral obligation
to bring you
the biggest stories of the day.
Because for many people,
let's face it,
and I don't say this lightly,
we are their Walter Cronkite.
People trust us to bring them
the stories that matter most
and to do it with poise
and moral clarity and gravitas.
In fact, Alex,
this one is so big,
can we go to black and white?
Great.
And, uh, cigarette, please?
Thank you very much.
Alright, let's do it.
Tonight we begin our show
with a story of immense
significance to the future
of our nation.
It involves
a deeply corrupt ex-president
who poses an existential threat
to democracy
and the accomplices
around him who aid
and abet
his criminal lawlessness.
According to
a blockbuster tell-all
by "New York Times" reporter
Maggie Haberman...
[ Laughter ]
Alex, I think we can bring
the color back now.
That's right -- Trump loudly
complained about
his lawyer's stinky dumps.
According to the book...
This is one of those
shocking stories
you also definitely
could have predicted.
No one thinks
Rudy is making good smells.
[ Laughter ]
It's why he's constantly voted
New York mayor
at least likely to have
his own fragrance.
[ Laughter ]
You know who's most likely?
Eric Adams.
I mean, cologne is probably
the solution
to the trash problem for him.
"I know that garbage
on the street smells bad.
That's why I never
leave the house
without putting on
some Swagger."
[ Laughter ]
So I'm not surprised Rudy makes
bad smells, but I am surprised
it's so bad that Trump
complained about it.
I mean, all Trump consumes
are Big Macs and Diet Cokes.
He probably has
one bowel movement a week
that looks like
the scene from "Jurassic Park."
[ Laughter ]
And of course,
even as he was running
for the most important job
in the world,
that was what Trump
was preoccupied with.
I'm sure it happened
after he won, too.
"Mr. President, North Korea
just launched a nuclear missile
into the --"
"God damn it, Rudy!
What the hell
did you do it here?
It's Air Force One,
not Air Force number two!"
I'm guessing the reason
Trump reacted so fast
was so he could
beat Rudy to the punch,
because Rudy definitely
has the vibe of a
"don't go in there"
kind of guy.
I mean,
Rudy immediately confesses
to everything
without prompting.
I'm shocked
he didn't do it on TV.
Remember all those
televised confessions?
-Did our State Department ask
you to go on a mission for them?
-They did.
And you know who I did it
at the request of?
The State Department.
It's all here.
Right here.
-So you did ask Ukraine
to look into Joe Biden?
-Of course I did.
-"Did you drink an entire bottle
of scotch with dinner?"
"Sure!"
"And did you eat
an entire prime rib?"
"Yes!"
"And how did your system
react to that combination?"
"Not well!"
"And did you destroy
the airplane lavatory?"
-Of course I did.
-I'm not --
[ Laughter ]
I'm not exaggerating
when I tell you
that this is
the most important story
we have ever covered
on this show.
This is our Watergate.
So many pieces of the puzzle
are finally falling into place.
For example, now we know
why Trump's always
complaining about toilets.
-People are flushing toilets
10 times, 15 times.
Sinks, toilets, and showers.
You don't get any water.
We won't talk about toilets.
But, you know a...
tink, tink, tink.
10, 15 --
but we don't talk about that.
Sinks, right? Showers.
And what goes with a sink
and a shower?
10 times, right? 10 times.
I won't talk about the fact
that people have to flush
their toilet 15 times.
-Now, in the past,
when I've heard that,
my reaction has been,
even for Donald Trump,
that seems like
a lot of flushes.
But now I know
there was a second pooper.
Also, I want to emphasize
that according to the book,
this happened in 2016 and Rudy
still went to work for Trump
for six more years.
I don't know about you guys,
but if my boss made it a point
to loudly complain
about how bad the bathroom
smelled after I used it
so that everyone else
could hear,
my response would not be
"I am willing
to go to jail for this man,"
because let's make it clear --
Rudy isn't the bad guy here.
Sure, he can make
some dietary adjustments,
but you reach a certain age
and it's going to be
what it's going to be.
Trump is the bad guy here.
Being Trump's lawyer
is the worst job in the world.
You don't get paid.
You're constantly
exposing yourself
to criminal charges.
And he loudly complains
about your bathroom smells.
"Rudy, you're a lawyer.
Could you help my toilet out?
It's trying to file
a restraining order
against your butthole.
[ Laughter ]
Do you guys hear what I said
about Rudy?
Did everybody
on the plane hear it?"
[ Laughter ]
We should be done
with this story by now,
and yet I still have
so many questions.
Like, for example,
they make it sound like
it was a regular thing.
Why was Trump always going into
the bathroom right after Rudy?
Was it just a revolving door
where these two Big Mac
receptacles go back and forth,
just absolutely wrecking
the airplane bathroom
until they landed?
"Knock, knock, anyone in there?"
"You know it's me, boss!
[ Laughter ]
I came in when you came out."
"Well, it's time again
for me, Rudy."
[ Laughter ]
I don't want to be
overdramatic here,
but we need a congressional
investigation into this.
Liz Cheney needs to work this
into the next January six
hearing.
And lest you think
I'm being silly, remember,
they did do an entire segment
at the hearings
about how Rudy was drunk
on election night.
-Was there anyone in that
conversation who,
in your observation,
had had too much to drink?
-Um, Mayor Giuliani.
-"And how did you know that
Rudy was at the White House
that night?"
-"Uh, there was police tape
on one of the bathroom doors.
[ Laughter ]
Also, this mask
isn't because of COVID."
[ Laughter ]
Now, as much as I'd love
to spend the rest of the show
on this story,
and believe me, we thought about
going live tonight to cover it,
but the network did not respond
to our many e-mails,
there are, I guess, some other
less important stories
in the news.
For example, the investigation
into all those
top-secret documents
Trump stole
from the White House
and stashed in the basement of
his Palm Beach
resort/luxury morgue.
And you can rest assured,
you can rest assured
there is no possible connection
between Trump's handling
of official government records
and the toilet story
we just told you about.
-Staff members at
the White House residence
discovered wads of printed paper
in a clogged toilet
and believe that
former President Trump
was trying to flush documents.
-In her new book,
Maggie Haberman
of "The New York Times" confirms
a habit of the former president
that wasn't just unhealthy
for the White House plumbing,
it was bad
for the presidency as well.
And she's got the photos
to prove it.
-Damn it, we can't get away
from this toilet story!
[ Laughter ]
Every time I think I'm out,
they flush me back in.
Even more shocking to me
is that both these stories
are in the same book
by "New York Times" reporter
Maggie Haberman.
She wrote a deeply reported
600-page tell-all
about the
most dangerous president
in modern American history.
And to do it, she had to spend
a significant amount of time
investigating
the weird toilet habits
of the grossest freaks on Earth.
Toilets have never played
such a large role
in American history before.
I mean, just look
at the index.
Here in the mentions of
Mike Pence in the book,
and here are the mentions
for toilets.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, that's it, I prom--
No more --
No more toilet stuff!
The point is,
Trump's habit of destroying
or stealing official
government records,
including top-secret documents
with the most sensitive
classified information,
is now under a very intense
federal criminal investigation.
So naturally,
Trump is once again
trying to manipulate
the courts to help him.
In fact, now he's going all
the way to the Supreme Court.
And in particular, his appeal
was addressed to a justice
who is very obviously
and blatantly compromised
in a way
that should disqualify him.
-We have
some breaking news to report
in the criminal investigation
into Donald Trump's handling
of classified documents.
Attorneys for the ex-president
made an attempt to block
DOJ's criminal investigation
by asking the US Supreme Court
to reverse a ruling
by an appeals court
that gives the DOJ access
to classified documents
that were seized at Mar-a-Lago.
-Notably, this request
from Trump's team
does go directly to
Justice Clarence Thomas.
-Clarence Thomas' wife,
who is a lawyer,
urged Republicans in state
legislatures around the country
to change the outcome
of the presidential election.
-No Supreme Court justice
in history
has ever been more
publicly compromised
by the conduct of a relative
than Clarence Thomas.
But today, Clarence Thomas
did not recuse himself
when Donald Trump's lawyers
filed their appeal
to the Supreme Court
directly to Clarence Thomas.
-That's right -- Trump's appeal
went directly to Clarence Thomas
because Clarence Thomas
is the justice with jurisdiction
over the 11th Circuit Court
of Appeals,
which issued the ruling
Trump is appealing.
And Thomas did not immediately
recuse himself,
which is obviously insane.
His wife, Ginni Thomas,
tried to help Trump
overthrow
a presidential election.
You can't pretend like that
just didn't happen.
That would be like
using the bathroom
right after Rudy Giuliani
and not saying
anything about it.
I said we wouldn't
bring it up again
and we brought it up again.
I'm very sorry.
Seriously, Clarence Thomas
shouldn't even be on the bench,
let alone ruling on cases
directly involving the guy
his wife teamed up with to
orchestrate an attempted coup.
For one thing, I seriously doubt
they never talked about it.
Can you imagine
any married person
saying with a straight face,
"Oh, no,
I've never heard any of
my spouse's insane opinions"?
Thomas involving himself
in this ruling
is even more ludicrous
given that his wife, Ginni,
just testified to the January
Six Committee last week.
During that testimony,
she actually stood by her belief
that the 2020 election
was stolen.
And then Trump praised her for
it at a rally over the weekend.
-Ginni Thomas,
the conservative activist
and wife of Supreme Court
Justice Clarence Thomas,
met today with the January
Six Select House Committee.
-We are told
that she cooperated,
that she answered
every question.
But Chairman Bennie Thompson
has also told reporters
that she still believes
the election was stolen, Jake.
So after everything we know,
Ginni Thomas is still
an election denier.
-I would like to thank a great
woman named Ginni Thomas.
Do you know Ginni Thomas?
[ Cheers and applause ]
She's a great woman,
the wife of a great man --
Justice Clarence Thomas --
for her courage and strength.
She said that she still believes
the 2020 election was stolen.
She didn't say, "Oh, well,
I'd like not to get involved.
Of course, it was
a wonderful election."
It was a rigged
and stolen election.
-I do like Trump's impressions
of other people
because they're all the same
regardless of who
he's talking about.
It doesn't matter if it's
Joe Biden or Ginni Thomas.
I'd love to see
his SNL audition.
"Next, I'll be doing
my Harry Styles impression.
Okay, here we go.
[ Clears throat ]
Hi, my name is Harry Styles.
I...I do songs
and spit on Chris Pine."
[ Laughter ]
But again, let's step back
and process
the order of things here.
Clarence Thomas' spouse
urged lawmakers
in several states
to overturn the 2020 election.
She texted Trump's
chief of staff
and urged him not to concede.
She then repeated those lies
to the January Six Committee.
Trump then praised her and her
husband at a political rally,
and now her husband is ruling
on a case involving Trump's
potentially criminal handling of
classified documents.
If that isn't
a brazen conflict of interest,
I don't know what is.
This is a conflict of interest
on the level of finding out
the Mets' pitching staff
we're secretly all Braves fans,
which would explain a lot.
Look, I don't want to pick
on the Mets,
but they're the only team
in the history of baseball
that could win 100 games
and still make their fans
feel absolutely
[bleep] miserable.
And maybe this Mets situation
doesn't affect all of you,
but I somehow work with
every single fan of the Mets,
and they've been walking around
all day this week
like they just used the bathroom
after Rudy Giuliani.
Which is ironic because we got
a few Rudys on the crew.
You know who you are.
[ Laughter ]
As gross and unimportant
as the Rudy toilet story is,
it's both, A, very funny
and, B, an example
of the kinds of humiliation
the people in Trump's orbit are
willing to endure to serve him.
And that orbit now includes
the spouse
of a Supreme Court justice
who is poised to rule
on a very serious
federal criminal investigation
into Trump's handling
of classified documents.
Trump has destroyed
the integrity
of our nation's institutions,
just as Rudy has destroyed
our nation's --
-Toilets!
-This...
has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
The midterm elections
are coming up.
So to make sure that you're good
to vote in this election,
visit our good friends
at HeadCount.org
to check your voter registration
status or to register to vote.